it's been chaotic very chaotic um
phones have been ringing everybody's all
over the place we're trying to remain
calm because we already knew this was
going to happen but it's hard to keep
your composure when you've been doing
something for so long it's been taken
away from you
and it's just been really really hectic
like everybody is like we have people
crying they're fragile
they're hurting they're hurting harder
than we are like we have to be strong
for them but when i say they're hurting
on the inside they're hurting like this
is a really hurting feeling from just
from the phone calls we get to yesterday
and today these patients are her team
like this is very very sad
to see and to hear them crying on the
phone
because they can't have an abortion in
the state of mississippi and a sense
that the patients are in a hurry because
they realize that things that this is
going to shut down soon yes they're very
terrified for it
a panicking everybody's panicking even
even the men are panicking they're
calling because they're trying to figure
out what is going on so yes like this is
very scary for the women in mississippi
texas louisiana just everywhere for this
to be going on because this isn't
this is the only clinic that's still
operating in mississippi but but you're
helping women from many other states
around it we get a lot of people from
everywhere but it's just like those
those places who don't have the clinics
the access to it they've been coming
here
and so for it to be shut off completely
it's sad
and just describe to me uh
the state of mind of the patients that
you've seen today everybody is very very
rare like that's all i can see i can see
the despair on their face i'm trying to
keep them calm like hey it's gonna be
okay there's other places you know you
may have to travel but they're gonna
have to travel
potentially to illinois i mean
hundreds and hundreds of miles yes yes
miles and it's just so sad that they
will have to go through this
how are you feeling about it as a as a
nurse as a someone who works here but
also as a as an american
i feel like that we've been ripped away
rip this has been ripped away from us
like not even having the choice to say
hey this is what i want to do this is my
choice like it's sad like i feel bad for
the generation that's coming up it's
hard to kind of describe
when you've been doing something for so
long and helping women and
now you can't do that anymore what would
you say to the supreme court justices
who made this decision
they was wrong
they made a very bad decision and i hope
that they're thinking about it and what
they're going to do to the women in
mississippi and all over pretty much
that was like a very very bad decision
and it's all games with it like it's
like it's not for i feel like these
people do not care about these women
that's coming into this clinton like how
we do
they just oh you're killing your baby
you're this you're dead
you don't care you would rather say that
than to actually care for this woman
what could you do to help this one
besides take her to a clinic and give
her a pregnancy test and an ultrasound
and say you're going to be a good mom go
on we can't really help you that's as
far as we go that's basically what
they're doing like it's not helping the
women they're not having the resources
that they need
and you're hunting too it looks like
yeah i can tell yes like just to be here
for so long
and now it's just like we already knew
it was coming but it's just like to know
that it's real
and this is how the state of mississippi
is handling
women's reproductive care
it's sad it's all a game for the for the
the legislator all those people the
governor it's a game for them to say
that they won that's all they want to
say we won is life life one that's what
they want to say
instead of really looking into
women's health
and the patients are suffering because
they want to win this political game
and to compound that
that pain that you talk about the the
patients who arrive here are being
shouted at by by anti-abortion people
and you were telling me you're getting
hate calls as well yeah we're getting
hate cows they're
cussing us out um death threats oh we
didn't we didn't get it all
it was just in two days like before this
evening came out
no problem
when that that ruling came out yes it
was real it was like
consistent cause patience calls patients
call patients so it's like i never got
the chance to stop and to really just
process everything that had just
happened
so yeah it's it's it's a it's a
it's a hard pill to swallow but we're
still going to be helping women at the
end of the day we're going to do
everything that we can to help these
ladies
and what happens now for
for women in mississippi
and in states across america i really
can't say what's going to happen but i
can just only imagine what's going to be
happening what i heard somebody say over
the phone what they're willing to do
because they can't have an abortion like
it saddens my heart so bad because i'm
like wow like
these people can only hear the phone
calls that we get now that we're getting
now about what they're going to do i
just hope that they don't take matters
into their own hands and just go about
it the proper way and get it done
because there's some people out here
like that they can't afford it so you
know things are going to happen it's
going to be all over the news just just
wait just wait it's going to be there
because it's already happening their
mind is already wondering
what is next what can i do how am i
going to do this